foreign
even though we are super attracted to
each other and we are intimate you know
I don't know the right way I guess to
get to that next step I think our
culture is obsessed
we're obsessed with intimacy equals
intercourse and I just reject that I
don't think that's accurate
[Music]
what up what up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
so grateful that you're with us
we're all gonna get learned up together
today if you want to be on the show
greatest mental health and marriage
podcast ever give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291
it's totally free
and that's about what the advice is
worth but hey we'll do it together or
you go to John deloney.com ask
a-s-k and don't forget to hit the
Subscribe button or the I love you
button or whatever buttons that you
don't suck but what are the buttons what
are they what are they
my wife tells me I was born in the wrong
century
well it depends on what they're
listening to that's what I thought yeah
just like to share hit the I love you
button whatever that means in the hive
mind in the internets hit that button
and don't hit the I don't like you
button because I'm sensitive all right
let's go to Mike in Pittsburgh Mike Mike
what's up dude
hey Dr John massive fan ears your book
redefining anxiety changed my life so
thank you so much I appreciate that man
I got a new follow-up on anxiety coming
out man I'm excited to get in your hands
I'll be great
oh awesome what's up dude great
yeah so uh I just recently got engaged
um we moved into an apartment together
um we've always had a really great
relationship
um I love her so much you know but it's
always felt like we're just past that
best friend's threshold in some ways
um even though we are super attracted to
each other and we are intimate you know
I don't know the right way I guess to
get to that next step
I'm not Sue so if we were just hanging
out just you and me I just we I just met
you and we're hanging out
it sounds like a guy who really wants
her to like him but she doesn't but I I
don't think that's the case here so give
me some more some more
uh Clarity here yeah there's more to it
you know she's always
I guess you know had trouble opening up
um physically
um she I think she has a lot of anxiety
about it
um and it's always limited or intimacy
Beyond a certain point
um it's been like five years that way
and then to throw another variable into
all of it you know I've become a lot
more religious
um and I found God accepted Jesus and
you know I know I shouldn't have sex
before marriage anyway so I'm really
honestly fine on waiting on that but I
don't know how to know that this will
change once we get married because
that's sort of what she's assured me on
um I just want to respect her you know
respect my religion
and I don't know how to achieve all of
those things moving forward I guess
I think our culture is obsessed
psychopathologically
we're obsessed with and this is
religious and non-religious
intimacy equals intercourse
and I just reject that I don't think
that's accurate I think everybody
intimacy means something different to
everybody and we can draw some big
generalized buckets here but with the
way you just described it what I'm
hearing is
um a woman who
is struggling with trust and is
struggling with feeling safe
and my guess is it her her challenges
with intimacy are are not just physical
she probably didn't tell you everything
that's going on maybe even keep secrets
from you or just says Ah it's okay am I
am I onto something or no
I I think you are I mean and I think I'm
I'm to blame too you know when I try to
talk about it sometimes I I think I get
a little frustrated and then I can see
her withdrawal I just shuts down yeah
yeah so the
anytime somebody says they've got
anxiety about a thing
um anxiety is not the issue there what
the issue is is that your body has
detected something that's not safe
Stephen poor just calls it uh
neuroseption your body is scanning the
environment it has found something
that's not safe
for any number of reasons you remind her
of an old boyfriend you remind her of
somebody that hurt her you remind her
you're the picture of the guy that's
pushing her past her boundaries for five
freaking years and she's tired of it but
she also loves you also doesn't have any
self look whatever the story may be it
could be a thousand different stories
and so I less want to figure out I mean
you
this is a broad generalized statement
here okay and so be nice to me on the
internet I'm painting with a broad brush
here
I'm finding in more and more couples
that I talk to more and more men and
women I talk to individually for some
particularly men intimacy is about sex
it's about connectivity it's about
desire and fantasy and when you feel
deeply desired enough that somebody is
revealing themselves to you then you can
tell them about the things that scare
you and the things that hurt you and the
things that you dream about like I want
to live in this kind of house I wanna
have this kind of job someday
and again broad General brush
it works opposite for women
I need to know what you're thinking I
need to know you're with me I need you
to hear me I need you to know that we're
on the same page and that is the gateway
to intimacy to my body does that make
sense
yeah and then when you don't have that
people go to war because you're both
using the word intimacy you're both
using the words we just want to get
closer you're both using the words love
and they look like completely different
things to each other
and then one of you gets mad one of you
shuts down and then you end up getting
engaged because that's going to solve it
and then you end up you see what I'm
saying and you end up in this dance and
that's when you get four or five or six
or seven years later one of you is
really frustrated one of you is
completely shut down one of you's gone
back to old roles and one of you starts
having a conversation with somebody at
work and they light you up for the first
time in a long time
yeah I think you've 100 nailed it there
um you know and and I think
you know from her perspective it
probably is that she's shut down and
that for me I'm I'm just completely
completely frustrated you know yeah yeah
um so she's not here and so I don't want
to spend a lot of time digging into what
she's thinking and why she's thinking it
my concern is that you
a don't feel like her lover you feel
like her best friend
um you have the safety part down but you
don't have the romance part down and
for you this is about a series of
actions
it's a series of steps she needs to do
things she needs to do to show herself
and you're starting to be concerned
about
down the road and what I don't even know
what down the road is we don't have to
go into it but is that are you like
wondering like is she gonna be wild is
she gonna like do all the crazy things
I've got in my head and all the things
I've Seen On TV like
or is it just not boring or like what
are you worried about in the future
well I I want to know I guess that we
can have a normal intimate relationship
that does include sex one day because
she's just so closed up you know it
doesn't have to be wild it doesn't have
to be like that I guess I just I want
some Assurance somehow
that it will happen and then she assures
me all the time that it will and you
know that she's not holding back for any
religious reason or any other reason
it's just that you know she's never
really done that with anyone you know so
it's it's just a really odd situation I
guess it's not odd at all
there's that's a young woman who's tired
of being pressured
so she shuts down I see
and
you have to decide
if pressure pressure pressure pressure
pressure
slowly wearing somebody down
if that's how you want to come into
connection with somebody
I do not want that for my life
yeah absolutely not and also I've been
doing that are you able to find
connection and Intimacy in a much
broader picture
in the way she thinks about you and
helps out and the way she
reaches out and says how can I love you
better and you reach out right it's so
much more than just intercourse man I
was so obsessed with it intercourse is
awesome
but it's not the end-all be-all of
intimacy right
um it's about both and I don't want to
just but you're the only one on the
phone right so if you are both here I'd
be having a conversation with both of
you so I don't want to sound like I'm
just kicking you while you're down but
um
I don't think I don't see this changing
even after you get married that's not
some magic switch because you have not
created a context where she feels safe
opening up to you and I'm not just
talking about sexually I'm talking about
all the way across the board
okay and so if I'm you a couple things I
would do number one
I would start and go first and say I'm
looking back over five years and I
realized I've created a world where I'm
on offense all the time and you're on
defense all the time
I've created a world where for whatever
reason
my presence the things are that that I
have identified that bring me
connectivity intimacy those things shut
you down they scare you and I think as a
couple we've got to call that out before
we get married
and I don't feel comfortable moving into
a long-term relationship when you don't
feel safe with me and I don't feel
comfortable moving into a relationship
long term
where I don't know how to make you feel
safe
and again it's not just you got to feel
safe so that you can have sex that's not
sex is off the table for me right now
this is a much bigger deal right
um I would recommend reading both of you
reading Come As You Are by Emily
nagatsky and both of you reading the
five love languages now the five love
languages doesn't have a lot of science
or anything behind it that I know of
maybe it does but more it gives you a it
gives you a framework I think there's
way more than five ways to communicate
but it gives you a framework for having
the same discussion instead of talking
past each other
does that make sense you all live
together yeah
yeah yeah we're in an apartment together
um and yeah usually that accelerates if
a couple in your situation usually if
they move in together
um it makes everything heightened and on
fire because you're St you thought that
by moving in together I would feel more
connected and less lonely and you
actually feel more lonely in a crowded
room
yeah I mean that that 100 true it's it's
just gotten worse but I'm willing to do
the things you said because I mean I
don't I don't even like the way that I
feel like I am in these situations if
that makes sense yeah
I think the more that you
and and again dude I I'm saying this
with all just due respect and love okay
the more you view her body as something
that's gonna fix you
or the more that if she would just do
these things then you would fill in the
blank
the more you're putting pressure you're
putting weight on her that she simply
can't carry
no person can carry that there's no such
thing as I complete you that whole thing
was a that was just a Tom Cruise movie
right right and here's the here's the
Paradox you can't do Life by yourself
either
and so I've got to have somebody with me
so that I can repel off the edge
not
um I've gotta have somebody with me or I
can't breathe
that's what I'm saying and I know it
gets all messy and esoteric I have you
all gone to couples counseling yet
no we haven't okay I can't think of
anybody I've talked to today that needs
to go more than you guys do
and the conversation is not how to be
more sexually connected or how to deal
with intimacy that's not it at all
I think you go first and you say I need
to learn how to make my wife feel safe
around me because for the last five
years I have not done a good job she
knows I love her she knows I think she's
beautiful I that she's the she's the
greatest in the world
but she doesn't her body doesn't feel
safe around me and I don't know what it
is but I want to I want to heal that I
want to be better about that
and that's the language I would take
into it
okay now that that helps a lot I I
didn't I never thought of framing it
that way anytime she says I'm feeling
anxious about just replace that word
anxious with your body's trying to tell
you you're not safe
and by the way sometimes your body's lie
sometimes they don't tell the truth
sometimes she doesn't feel safer on you
because of some somebody else did a long
time ago
right right but it at least let's go
there
why is her body saying this guy's not
safe we we can't trust this guy why is
everybody saying
I gotta shut down I gotta hide I gotta
shut down I gotta hide why
why is that
and what part of you is bringing that on
what part of you is setting is just
pouring gasoline on that fire one part
of that is completely totally you right
and it may be nothing to do with you but
y'all are in this thing together okay so
get those two books Come As You Are by
Emily nigotsky
um it's a it's the best book on sex I've
read and it gives a couple's common
language it's actually written for women
but I think it's a great book for men to
read too
um it's not a faith-based book or
anything like that but it's it's it's
outstanding and the five love languages
book will just give you all a common set
of words to use together
um
that can maybe begin to give you all a
path and you need to go call it marriage
counselor we're seeking safety here my
brother thank you for being open man
we'll be right back
I've got a word from our sponsor
betterhelp listen I've been on both ends
of therapy in my life I've gotten it
myself and I've walked people through it
and I've seen the benefits from both
sides when someone owns their past and
the cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
all right let's go to Lisa in Missoula
what's up Lisa
hi what's happening
hi not much good morning good morning to
you is the world uh spinning in your
area
um yeah it seems to be seems to be good
over here why do y'all keep letting all
those balloons go over there what are
you doing
I played no part in any of it sure sure
Lisa
we're on to you hey uh before you
continue your question with Lisa you
don't see this and I want to make sure
that you all have this discussion on
Lisa's email she signed off as proud dog
mom and continue oh
oh
yeah and that was on purpose and I'm
sorry Hey listen we all need to live in
our own little delusions and if this is
the one for you then so be it and thank
you
he looks really cute in a sweater that's
all I'm gonna say
uh uh Kelly just carries like a small
vial of gas in her purse and so when she
sees any small flame she's like ooh and
then she just dumps gasoline on it just
to watch things burn so I love her for
it are you calling about being in dog
mom please say yes
no
easy okay so uh what do you want to talk
about what's up
yeah well um at the end of the day the
question is and just
um in acknowledging how anxiety changes
I'm I'm wanting some really practical
tips on on how I can get this under
control and then
um secondary to uh that because I
emailed in and my question kind of
changed after we had scheduled this but
um learning to trust my spouse how to
relearn how to trust him when I feel
like with all this anxiety I can't even
trust myself anymore what do you do
story and I prepped some notes okay I'll
run through it quickly okay
so um back story depending on how I
interpret the the questions I'm a seven
two and eight on the Asus exam
um I I hear that I see that but I also
acknowledge that I turned it around I
did the work
um life is good
um I'm living the quote end quote middle
class American dream I have a great dog
uh great job great house right
um I've always struggled with anxiety
um I well I say always I didn't know I
was struggling with anxiety until maybe
three years ago okay can I pause you
right here can I pause you right here
yeah yeah
if you were with me right now I would
say ask you if I had permission to give
you a hug
and what I would do is not in a weird
creepy way
um
but I would want to give you a hug for
like 15 or 20 seconds past where it got
awkward
to where your shoulders would finally
drop for a second
you just you just rattled off a really
common response to Childhood trauma
which is I will out achieve this thing
I'll outrun it with my house size square
footage and I'll outrun it with my
salary I'll run it with my how good
looking my husband is I'll outrun it
with a car that I drive
and it will catch you and it will bury
you right
yeah it feels right and I think that's
exactly what's happened well you said
here's here's the big tell for me is
your anxiety keeps moving on you
yeah and it's it's
some people have a phobia about a
particular room in their house because
that's where their child passed away
like they can't go in that room their
body is identified they put a GPS pin in
that room this room's not safe
that's not what your body's doing
your body has identified the world is
unsafe and as soon as you get a grasp on
something
because you're so strong you're out
running a seven or eight on the aces
you're so strong you're able to grab
hold of these things and wrestle it to
the ground and then kind of like a like
a balloon animal it squirts out
somewhere else and something else it
jumps on something else
and it's because you're not healing from
the center and I'm gonna even push you
further and say
I've come to believe with all the
reviews of the literature and all of the
Swan diving into all the narrow
chemicals and all that all the stuff
that only a few of us nerds really care
about
at the end of the day healing from
anxiety
teaching your body that you're safe is
about Connection in a relationship
and traumatized people
that's the demon of trauma is
it makes relationships the the the
monster and so your body identifies
relationships as something I can't get
into and if you don't have relationships
you can't breathe
yeah and so then it makes everything it
spins your alarms and says we can't
breathe we can't breathe then you're
like oh I'm gonna reach out to my
husband because I love him and then your
body's like no
and then like a good husband he goes and
does something stupid
or a whole bunch of things stupid or in
a weird gross dance
he starved for connection too and he's
got a woman that he loves who's sleeping
next to him and he can feel the nuclear
reactor in her chest
and he starts to think well maybe it's
me and then somebody somewhere lights
him up
it makes him feel a little bit more
alive am I onto something tell me I'm
right or wrong
you're heading in the right direction
but I got a hard left turn for you okay
bring it
yeah so I've been with my husband for
five years total two and a half of those
married
um intimacy at the beginning was really
great it did taper off pretty early
um and yeah why well well I'll get
okay
it's been an issue on going
um a lot of fights and I've been
unfortunately growing some resentment
about it
um while we were still dating he had a
bit of a a text Affair if you will an
emotional affair
um that I I was able to heal from and
forgive him and and we moved on uh
it was yeah it was a whole thing
um okay so yeah you're speaking trauma
language I'm gonna call it every time I
hear it okay I didn't have a bit of an
affair
he cheated on you
yeah okay yeah and you are great at
peacekeeping and you are great at
minimizing
yep okay yeah
yep no thank you all right and then so
you went through with marriage you
forgave them you said we're gonna we're
gonna make this make a run at this thing
and then yep
yep flirtation at an affair
um that he swears up and down was
short-lived nothing physical happened
and
um during this confrontation he then
proceeded to admit to me that for the
entirety that I have known him and for
as long as he can remember he's had a
porn addiction
um and he works on the road and um you
know he's gone three nights a week and
he's been struggling with that and I'm
just I I feel like maybe that's why
intimacy is failing but he's also been
lying to me the entire time I've known
him and
I'm
I don't even know how to like close my
dialogue for the backstory because I
just I'm I'm at such a loss I don't I
don't
I'm Bamboozled yeah
um yeah so there's no surprise that
you're anxious because your body's been
trying to get your attention for a long
time
that it did it since something was not
right at home
and
on top of as much trauma as you've
experienced you learned at an early age
you need to take those feelings and bury
them in the backyard because they just
get you hurt
we've got things to solve we've got
things to achieve we've got things to
crush and kill and drag home we don't
have time for this
digging into what's making me feel
uncomfortable
right and so good for you you learned
how to move on right and not good for
you once again the person who's at the
bottom is you here's what's so
disorienting man and it breaks my heart
for you you've built your entire
identity on top of this trauma not from
a place of healing but from a place of
accomplishment and achievement and I can
do all things Lisa will take control
and
they can't control this
and so now you've lost troll trust in
Lisa
how did I miss this I've been prepped
for this you see what I'm saying
yeah
can I tell you I'm sorry
thanks how did your conversation end
now I've I've listened to a lot of your
show
um probably almost every episode and I I
re-listened to the ones I need to hear
again and I read and I do the things and
I know I either have to be all in or all
out and I do really love this guy and so
I've chosen to be all in
um and
I it's it seems good now and I but it's
not and I can't just I can't keep
pretending let me tell you where I
failed you okay oh yeah I should add I
should add a caveat you gotta be all in
or you got to be all out
but sometimes when the wound is deep
when the wound hurts when there's been
years of systemic lying and covering up
and multiple affairs
sometimes I can't be all in right now
and I should have added that a long time
ago and I'm sorry
for the first time in your life you've
got to find a place where you feel safe
enough to say what you actually think
and what you're actually feeling
I'm pissed you should be sorry say it
say it Carl ramrod say it
I am so freaking pissed yeah keep going
I
want to punch him in the face I mean
that's not that's not a solution but I
do I mean I'm considering it keep going
I just there's got to be something
better out there right there's not
something but like better energy better
existence and like why why what was so
wrong with me that this had to happen
again there it is and listen to me very
very carefully
your husband's dealing with demons that
have nothing to do with you
and it would actually in your mind be
easier if this was about you because
then you could have something to fix
your husband's lying to you because
something's wrong with him
your husband's cheating on you because
he's wrestling with his own issues
and maybe I just just for full honesty
and it may be that he has been with you
and he can't figure out a way to connect
with you
okay
my estimation that doesn't give license
for what's happening but it might
provide a context okay it's not an
excuse but it might say like I'm trying
and it didn't work out instead of having
the courage to say this isn't a good
relationship for me he went ahead and
married you and instead of being honest
with you and saying Hey I want to work
through this thing together he lied to
you and instead of saying I feel
I don't like who I'm becoming in this
relationship he went and found somebody
else that says well I like you
yeah okay yeah
this isn't you
what do I do set that thing down you
tell me
I don't know that's why I called you
no I'm at a loss but do you want to be
married to him
yeah he's dumb but I really like him
that's not dumb don't apologize for that
um Gina break
well that's the confusing part is I want
nothing more but to be around him right
now
is that reality or is that your trauma
I have no idea that's that's confusing I
I I don't know do you have sexual abuse
in your past
none that I can remember okay well and I
was listening to one of your shows and I
um started dating quote unquote at 14
and my first boyfriend was 18 and
according to you that's not healthy so
maybe
not right they're not great
um not great
um
do do
somebody leave when you were a kid
yeah
so
we talk a lot about it and I don't
exactly I don't know who if I've
mentioned on the show surely I have
we all know about fight or flight
response we all know about fighter
fighter freeze response a fourth yeah
uncommon one that we don't talk about a
lot is fawn
fight flight or freeze or Fawn where I'm
gonna nuzzle up
and become extra lovable to the person
who's hurting me because maybe that'll
keep him from hurting me again
and I'm asking you is that what you're
doing
are you so terrified in your at the
cellular level that he's gonna leave if
you take a break
that you can't imagine a world where
somebody else leaves and so you're going
to continue to get cheated on continue
to get lied to you're going to continue
to wade into his storms
because the alternative is you might end
up by yourself and it's not I can't do
that again
please
I don't want you to be mad at yourself
for loving him you're not there's
nothing wrong with you you're not broken
it's your husband and I don't want you
to like man anybody's like oh you should
just leave him and shut up nobody you
only person who can answer that question
is you
but I want to be honest about
um
sometimes you gotta you gotta take a
break from the sparring session because
you're hurt yeah
um
what does uh regaining trust look like
for you like if you snapped your fingers
and said this is how I'm gonna start
trusting this guy again what would that
look like
where I don't ask ask me every morning
um
if he looked at anything overnight
or question him when he interacts with
women at work that's going to be a long
long time
yeah
and I'll tell you right now I want you
to keep asking that question because
you're going to be tempted to stop
asking that question because you don't
want to make him feel uncomfortable
anymore you don't want to hassle him or
nag him and you're going to take your
feelings once again and shove them so
far down that you body can't breathe
the difference here is I want you to
call it out I'm going to ask you every
single day for the next three months
we'll revisit it
but the asking is one part what if he
just lies because he's been doing it for
so long that's where he was about to say
you have to have the if then statement
if you lie to me again I'm out yeah
yeah if you
text another woman that you're not
married to that's not me I'm out
yeah
I don't personally I don't believe him
that he hasn't been with somebody
yeah and that's just my default setting
in that kind of situation multiple times
over multiple years especially knowing
I've got a wife who's particularly
sensitive to this particular issue
um you gotta prove to me otherwise I'm
just going with
if it's if it you know smells like a
fire it's probably fire
do you have
what else does he not tell you the truth
about
and don't say nothing because I won't
believe you
I have
I've been questioning that same thing I
I mean when he tells me he loves me or
he likes me or he is sexually attracted
to me it all feels like lies now
yeah and that's a weird thing there's
some really remarkable research in
writing probably the most eloquent
writer on this is Esther perel
um
and what got her down the rabbit hole
that she ended up becoming like one of
the most important voices in the world
on was she kept meeting with clients who
had really extraordinary marriages
and then someone would go cheat
and it wasn't about sexual attraction it
was about financial attraction and it
wasn't about they didn't have the same
values and they had just helped
somebody's they just sat together while
one of their parents had died of cancer
like they've been through hell and back
together they were a good marriage
and ultimately that's where I take that
that's she's the one who gave me that
idea that I think is so profound and I
continue to see it over and over and
over again when she illuminated it which
is
most of the time people cheat most of
the time people go seeking stimulation
somewhere else from somebody else
whether it's texting whether it's
um somebody's only fan site whether it's
pornography whether it's actually
meeting somebody and creating new
relationship whether it's just a one
night hookup
it's because they don't like who they've
become in their relationship
yeah
and so I think the challenge here might
be you deciding this is who I want to be
married to
and giving him a sense of these are the
values this is the person that I want to
be married to somebody who's got enough
courage to go deal this crap with a
counselor somebody who goes and to a
Celebrate Recovery Group or somebody who
meets with a group of men every week to
hold each other accountable
somebody who goes nine months in our
house with no internet
someone who doesn't have a cell phone
whatever that looks like
yeah and I want you to stop apologizing
for
wanting some thresholds of trust in your
marriage and in your home because you're
not the one that took them out
maybe I'm a
woman you're not maybe it was the text
again even if it was that's the trauma
talking
trauma right like it just it happened
and it was so out of my control like
it's whatever moving on and listen and
we do I've done a terrible job also on
my show over the course talking about
post-traumatic growth
people become incredibly strong and
Incredibly connected and become
incredible leaders and have incredible
families
following trauma
post-traumatic growth is a very very
real thing so I don't want to minimize
it you're not broken forever
I gotta look at I gotta look at the
epidemiological data right you're more
likely to have X and Y and Z growing up
that's just a fact that just is and
when I look around my community most
everybody I see experience some pretty
hard stuff growing up on a big scale or
on a little scale
hey man there's some pretty amazing
people who've come from some pretty
amazing places and I count you as one of
them
I would love to see you talk to a
counselor not to even heal from
childhood trauma I'd love to see you
meet with a counselor to begin to listen
to Lisa's voice for the first time in
your whole life
would you do that
yeah yeah
to learn how to create boundaries
and not apologize for them
yeah
I want you to pick up
um Nidra to Webb t-a-w-e-b her book is
called find boundaries find peace I
think is the title
um I just read it recently it is
outstanding
uh but I think it's a book worthy of you
reading it okay
okay
I also want you to hang on the line I'm
going to send you a copy of all your
past change your future and
um
just as my gift to you
and I want you to read that as well but
I want you to to before the day is over
I want you to call a counselor
not because something's wrong with you
but because you got some new skills to
learn
and the new skills to learn are trusting
Lisa's body for the first time
ever
learning to identify when your body's
telling you you're not safe or you're
disconnected which it's been trying to
get your attention for a long time
that's anxiety
and three how to practice and set and
Implement boundaries and then hold them
in your new marriage because your
marriage is new now what was is over now
you and your husband get to build
something completely new and y'all gotta
figure out what that's going to look
like
he needs to go see somebody too because
he's struggling with feeling dead inside
and that's not on you that's on him
he's gonna have to do that work to
decide why he keeps self-sabotaging and
why he's become so unhappy with himself
in his role as your husband
that's his journey to do and you'll
probably end up in marriage counseling
which would be fantastic
[Music]
but you're right to be upset and you're
right to be heartbroken or you're white
you're right you want to start swinging
all those feelings are right
he's got that scary scary terrifying
question what am I gonna do now
and I'll walk with you every step of the
way and I'm happy to talk to him too if
he wants to give me a shout thanks for
your bravery we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at ask
John ramseysolutions.com that's ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we're back um so we had a call
scheduled that was coming in
um from a firefighter who uh I actually
talked to before
he has been through hell and back and he
was going to be brave and be on the show
and then he got called to a fire
and I guess saving his neighborhood and
keeping people safe is more important
than my the greatest podcast ever
what's up with First Responders these
days picking service and help over
getting famous I'm just kidding
I don't think anybody's getting famous
on this show
um but but so I've got a new segment
it's called oh man I made people mad on
the internets again does that sound good
I think that sounds great and we should
have plenty of uh of things to talk I'm
finding out that's one of my spiritual
gifts that's one of my love language
it's the sixth secret love language
making people mad on internet here's
what I posted guys I'm
so much drama
so much drama here's what I wrote
one time my wife and I went to see a
romantic comedy movie
the movie was tragic funny and Charming
about as good as the genre can be
um what it was the movie just like no
secrets it was the
um
they they go to the jazz clubs
oh uh La La Land La La Land I loved it I
loved it not me I thought it was great
um
and as we walked out of La La Land
they're dancing the whole movie and this
great jazz and they're just having all
these moments in the jazz clubs and it's
all Smoky and dark and they're dancing
and falling in love and then it ends and
the only way it could end spoiler alert
terribly it's so good it's so good
back to my post back at the car I had a
thought
I just paid two Hollywood actors to
pretend to be in love to go dancing
together to hang out in jazz clubs and
pretend to live happily ever after
why hadn't I just taken my wife dancing
I paid someone else to do it for me
may I never Outsource my marriage to
strangers and screens again
some of you were super mean on the
internet
going to the movies is fine you're such
a loser to Looney oh my gosh you're
always lecturing us about it
number one
I'm not a big fan of Xanax but y'all
should take a bunch number two
I know the movies are fine I like
watching movies I'm a huge movie nerd I
love it
and
I have found myself and the culture with
without with which I live in
we are the outsourced generation we
Outsource everything
we Outsource our relationships we
Outsource our work we Outsource our
chores at home we Outsource work on our
cars we Outsource our food delivery we
Outsource everything
and it occurred to me
huh
I probably talked about it on the show
and this is I'm just thinking about it's
just just now
so Kelly you may have to edit this out
this idea of of soul mates
star-crossed lovers
right and I think I've mentioned on the
show that whole idea of soul mates comes
from
two 13 year olds who want to hook up and
they ended up
secretly getting married and then died
in a murder-suicide plot Romeo and
Juliet that's how we that's the standard
we hold up to the most romantic story
ever told it's not it was two idiotic
Teenagers Who Died
it's not romance at all not even close
to romance
it's two idiotic teenagers who didn't
have
Tick Tock it probably would have saved
everybody a bunch of trouble
and then I think of my grandparents who
were married 70 something years
and they got married super young and
then my granddad went to World War II
and they came back and they raised four
kids the idea of a soul mate what what
in the world
nonsense and then
after 50 years
60 years 70 years of marriage
they're both just sitting in chairs
going what huh huh
then my granddad passed away
and my grandmother
made several comments to how like her
body didn't work
because a part of her body on the left
and so I realized over 70 years they
became soul mates because they lived in
the trenches together and they did life
together and they did
the Vietnam War together worried about
their boys getting taken off to war they
did recessions together they did we
don't have enough money for food they
did kids getting in trouble they did
grandkids passing away they did all that
together and over time because they
didn't Outsource their relationships
if they were going to have joy they
weren't going to pay somebody else to do
it because they didn't have that kind of
money they had to go dancing
they had to go for a walk and hold hands
they had to figure it out
and I walked out of that movie and
thought I I a few places in the world
make me happier than a jazz club I love
them I love The Pianist I love the music
I love the Mad Jazz and I'm like what
are y'all doing and my brain starts to
have a minor
epileptic episode like I love it
I like the blue lights I like the whole
thing
I just paid 40 or whatever it cost to go
to the movies now
for somebody else to do that for me and
me and my wife just sat there eating
popcorn and Twizzlers and then we just
went home
I'm kind of done with that
kind of done with it
at the end of my life I want there not
to be much tread left on the tires and I
don't want to butt cheek imprints in my
couch
I want to have lived my life not paid
somebody else to live it for me
and that comes to my parenting that
comes to romance that comes to
Adventures that comes to all of it
and I remember when we lived downtown
Nashville we had no backyard Hank and I
would go on something we called
Adventure walks he was really young he
was whatever uh eight or nine we would
collect odd weird things in alleys
it was wild little nuts and bolts and
sticks and metal pieces and
stuff I'd be like yeah everybody want to
touch that let's don't touch that or I'd
cover it up with leaves because I was
like whoa
but we went searching for adventure and
we often found it or we'd spend an hour
chasing one lizard around it like we
just went and found Adventure here's my
point stop Outsourcing your life
guys take her dancing
I Don't Dance I'm shut up and take her
dancing
wives go to that dumb concert just go
just go
even if you're like it's too loud get
ear plugs just go
listen to the music on the way to on the
way to work when you're by yourself
I've been practicing listening to
country music so my son will love me a
little bit more and now I got
kind of that's a secret if you tell
anybody I'm gonna call you fire
the end of the day
stop Outsourcing your life whatever that
looks like for you go get your own
groceries if you can do your laundry
don't just call Jeff Bezos for
everything actually make a list and go
to Home Depot and shake hands with one
of those old guys they're awesome
stop Outsourcing your life build your
own treehouse
stop Outsourcing your life we'll be
right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap this up
um
man I I did not know Kelly got back from
the tattoo parlor last night and we're
all excited um she got a new
an incredible if you remember when
Prince changed his name to a symbol she
got that symbol it's it's incredible
it's all the way down the back of one of
her legs and she always wears really
short shorts to work and so everybody
get to see it all the time
but I asked her what her favorite Prince
song was and she immediately launched
into this classic
I never meant to cause you any sorrow I
never meant to cause you any pain all he
wanted one time to see you laughing
I only want to see you laughing in the
Purple Rain I never wanted to be your
weekend lover I only wanted to be some
kind of friend baby I could never steal
you from another it's a shame our
friendship had to end
Purple Rain
[Music]
due to uh shoot her some messages on
Instagram if you actually know what
Purple Rain is
we'll see you soon